by all outward appearances I should hate
How to Train Your Dragon this has so
many things I can't stand in a movie the
geeky dweeb who becomes the hero the
prejudiced parent who will never listen
the misunderstanding that'll break them
apart and just result in them opeing and
doping the hiding the pet so that nobody
season a lean towards modern-day talk in
a fantasy world this is stuff I usually
can't stand but for some reason here it
really really works there's just
something about the way the story is
told and presented and pasted that just
really really gets it it's almost like I
was hearing this story for the first
time even though I've heard it a million
times before which is fine because the
people who did this also directed lilo
and Stitch another movie that's been
done a million times but seemed very
fresh and new when they put their spin
on it and this movie works very much the
same a young boy lives in a world of
Vikings who spend most of their time
trying to fight off dragons why because
they believe dragons are evil and who
can blame them they constantly attack
breathe fire and are just dangerous
animals but the boy starts to see things
a little differently when he comes
across a wounded dragon in the middle of
a field so the boy decides to study him
as he spends more and more time with him
he realizes that dragons are not
inherently evil they're like any other
animal as long as they can be understood
they can be trained to be peaceful and
he uses this advantage to fight off
other dragons in a sense he doesn't
really fight them he actually finds
nonviolent ways to defend them off which
gets the attention of the village and
more importantly his father who always
regard him as a bit of a disappointment
but now finally see something they can
connect with budgie will the truth be
revealed and will the father's prejudice
get in the way to where he says he
doesn't have a son and all that other
stuff
yes but it's actually done pretty good
here the only thing I can think of as to
why it works here and not in other
stories is that the pacing is just so
good in that every single time something
happens you see how it affects the
character you see when the boy learns
something that it'll
sink in you see him actually taking the
time to figure stuff out with the Dragon
even his father you can see sore the
turmoil he's going through with trying
to love his son live with his son aid
his son he goes back and forth like a
real human being would and not just a
one-dimensional character he's not just
a bad guy he's a human being
who happens to have a prejudice but as a
prejudice you can well understand that
doesn't mean it doesn't break his heart
when he has to disown his son and maybe
that's what makes it stand out
every emotion feels genuine when the
characters are happy they feel genuinely
happy when they're jealous they feel
genuinely jealous and when they're are
broken you really feel how heartbroken
they are and I think so much of that
just comes from the fact that they take
the time to let us know these people and
it's not rushed the flying scenes are
unbelievable I mean they are just
beautiful to look at when this movie
came out it was in 3d and I still stand
by this is the greatest looking 3d movie
I've ever seen even better than avatar I
saw it in IMAX and it blew me away every
time there is a flying scene you felt
like you were on this dragon and you
were riding through the canyons I don't
know what they did how they did it but
more movies need to do it or at the very
least re-released this movie so we can
see it again in IMAX 3d cuz I know a lot
of people who didn't see it that way and
they should see it that way but the
great thing about the film is even if
you take that aspect out of it it's
still a good story and there's still
good characters it's one of the few
movies that can have this combination of
things I usually don't like and can
somehow really pull it off it can be
funny it can be harsh and it can be very
very genuine the one problem I have with
the film is once we revealed exactly how
the Dragons work even to this day I'm
sort of confused how it all goes down
it's like there's a giant dragon and all
the little dragons have to feed that
giant dragon so they're kind of slaves
but they can just fly off if they wanted
couldn't they why do they have to return
to this dragon why is that the reason
they have to attack the people it's
pretty confusing Oh once again they make
up for that with just how creative and
cool the dragons are and how different
each one is and how they function each
one has their weakness each one has
their strengths each one even sir has
its own
personality like I said before a lot of
time went into the details of this bill
I think it's just a straight-up
wonderful flick if at any point you can
see it in IMAX in 3d definitely take
advantage of it but if not it's still a
great film regardless